donc quand je suis debout et que je veux
faire ma
voix des énergies unifiées c'est art
martial créa l'ère médiévale par les
chefs de clan japonais arrivée il y a
seulement 30 ans en France et enseigné
au bout de club de Magny-les-Hameaux
reste en art martial de défense toujours
dans une volonté d'équilibre où il faut
utiliser les mouvements de son
partenaire pour riposter et le mettre à
terre tout en gardant le contrôle
l'équipe vidéo c'est bien effectivement
un art martial de défense comme le
voulait mettre yoshiba à l'origine de
l'Aïkido on utilise toujours l'énergie
en fait de l'adversaire pour le
canaliser et la retourner contre lui on
considère vraiment la personne qui
travaille avec nous c'est notre
partenaire il y a un respect qui est
très important au niveau de l'équiludo
c'est pour ça j'aime bien faire le
distinguo avec c'est pas un sport de
combat c'est vraiment un art partiel un
art martial est là pour vraiment
développer l'harmonie avec le partenaire
les clés articulaires sont tout aussi
importantes que l'apprentissage de la
chute sans un contact parfait avec le
sol les mouvements peuvent vite devenir
dangereux d'où l'importance de contrôler
riposte et partenaire à la fois une
retenue qui permet de voir le quotidien
autre à la sortie du tatami une
philosophie digitte non agression
indépendant la discipline peut-être un
peu plus de calme par rapport aux
agressions de la vie de tous les jours
pour le stress de tous les jours comme
on vit des situations stressantes
contrôlées finalement ça nous aide dans
la vie de tous les jours peut-être sur
des situations un peu je dirais
inhabituelles ou agressive et ben avoir
une réaction un peu comme on va voir sur
le totem le maniement des armes l'autre
facette de l'Aïkido du couteau à la
lance les techniques de combat sont
regroupées sous le terme de kobudo quel
que soit la technique il n'y a pas
réellement d'affrontement pas de
vainqueurs ni de vaincu mais deux
partenaires sur le tatami